you
in an uncertain and unpredictable world
there should be comfort in science the
rigour of experimental practice the
painstaking employment of scientific
methods but progress in research is far
from a smooth ride the Eureka moments
that have defined our world require one
extra ingredient of course science
success in science discovery on the
other hand I think one prepares oneself
for that luck difference luck meant
Archimedes had a bath that fateful day
but it was the years of study that laid
the foundations for the groundbreaking
insight in the words of vaccine pioneer
Louis Pasteur in the fields of
observation chance favors the prepared
mind and it's often the tiny details or
apparent mistakes that hold the key for
hematologist Peter our gray
there was one protein turning up in all
his tests that by all rights shouldn't
have been there a protein that would
eventually lead to a Nobel Prize in our
case with the water channel proteins we
were at work on the rhesus blood group
antigen which had never been understood
among at a molecular level and we
discovered a new molecule which I think
a smarter and more focused scientist
would have ignored but having a bit of
this attention deficit can sometimes be
helpful like thousands of researchers
curiosity had got the better of him the
few preliminary investigations he and
his team made only deepened the mystery
turned out to be one of the most
abundant proteins in the membrane of
erythrocytes with with sequence
similarity to proteins which had been
cloned from the root
of plants from the brains of insects
something altogether different so it was
like now it's like my goodness is it
what is it it must be something very
fundamental and in fact we were stuck
and we thought this must be a channel
protein for channel of some sort I was
assured by all the experts that red
cells did not have channels couldn't
possibly be correction it was a
discussion with a clinical mentor who
was a very good physiologist said that
in fact red cells were believed to have
channels for water but no one had ever
isolated that protein getting an inkling
of an idea is only the beginning proving
that idea experimentally is an entirely
different matter yeah the great
discoveries are made by intensely
focused individuals who who take
something incredibly difficult seemingly
the seemingly impossible and beat it to
death until it yields well there was a
lot of frustration and a lot of banging
my head against the wall so to speak I
rarely did literally sometimes there are
ups and downs let me rephrase they are
failures and maybe the number of
failures is even greater than the number
of successes failure for me is maybe
maybe better than success in many ways
because this is the lesson that will
drive me to success at the end of the
day even with an outlook this positive
it's not just failed experiments you
have to contend with after all when you
try to challenge an accepted theory
you're going to be met with a lot of
resistance you have to be prepared to
fight your corner absolutely absolutely
and if there's some question about
whether you're right or not then of
course you better think it through very
carefully but if you feel you're right
then you should muster your arguments
and absolutely finally even with the
world against you if the data is telling
you that the textbooks are wrong then
there's no choice but to continue to
keep polishing your experiments until
there can be no doubt about your
discovery
then one day either by chance or design
it all just comes together when we
express this new protein and just
transfer the oocytes from isotonic
solutions to distilled water an amazing
thing happened
they first like popcorn so there are a
few different breakthrough stages but
that initial experiment where all of the
tests oocytes exploded like popcorn we
knew we had it
genuine breakthroughs a few and far
between
perhaps it's the rarity of success that
makes them all the more exciting we were
planning to do a specific experiment
that would allow us to see the ions we
hadn't collected the data and I was
processing it and very tired in the
night and and came to a point where I
get to first look at it and I wasn't
excited yet at all because I didn't
think the experiment would work you know
in principle it should work but on
principle lots of things should work you
know it would be too good to be true to
work but it did I knew of experiments
from almost 50 years before by Hodgkin
and keynes where they determined they
did a simple measurement but thought
hard about it and said you know whatever
this mechanism is that allows potassium
to cross the membrane it has to involve
something like two to three ions in a
queue that was 50 years ago and I was
sitting there in the lab by myself at
two o'clock in the morning looking at
three ions in a queue and you know I was
running around I was running around in
the lab with hysteria and joy you know
having seen this to realize that you're
getting it you're kind of getting a
little logic of nature for the first
time it's a
such an exciting feeling and this is
years possibly even decades before this
discovery could have any possible use
the reward is just the pure wonder of
seeing something completely new we
didn't know where it going to lead we
didn't know that it's going to lead to
understanding disease mechanisms we
drugs we didn't know that it's going to
rescue the lives of thousands of people
but we sense that it's novel that
nothing like that was discovered before
and then we said well we looked left we
looked right there was no paradigm to
follow we went to the library there was
nothing like that
it was completely know the moment there
was on one hand the moment of elation
but on the other hand the moment of
loneliness
you are alone nobody to ask so it's kind
of a mixed moment but it was wonderful
these moments of elation are what keep
chemists returning to their benches and
with armies of scientists toiling around
the world it does beg the question will
we ever run out of breakthroughs the
wonderful thing about science is that
knowledge is endless and for every
question that we are answering we are
opening 10 new ones and if to use the
language that was used I don't take the
credit of a Nobel laureate in physics in
2004 David gross and the only product of
knowledge is more ignorant we are
generating more unknown which is
beautiful because people are asking me
what would happen one day if we know
everything I said don't worry this day
will never come
you